OILERS IN THE WHIT
KNOCKED OFF HIS STICK BY
AHEAD.
ACROSSN
HUBERDEAU OFA COUPLE OF GOOD CH.
SCORE! PUCK.
IT'S MAROON GETS IT TO THE NET.
LET'S SEE HOW THIS PUCK COMES
IE WITH IT ONCE AGAIN.VSKIY DRO
KNEE IN AND WHEN HE DROPS IT IN
WHERE DOES H
SCORE! FEET.
ONCE HE WENT TO HIS KNEES, SOME
PLAYS.
>> Keith: HE IS S R 3:00 GONE B
PERIOD.
2-1 LEAD FOR THEB BY
BRAYDEN POINT.
HOOK AROUND THE H.
THAT'S WHERE THE PENALTY WAS, I
BELIEVE.
THEN HE JUST STAYS W
HEDMAN SHOT THAT, MISSES THE
NET.
NUGENT-HOPKINS OUT OF TH
KILLORN AND THEN HEDMAN LOST THE
HANDLEAD A CHANCE TO BE SEDARNE.
>> Kenny: PUCK COMES INTO THE
SLOT.
SCORE!
SERG HYMAN
MOVING IT.
VASILEVSKIY.
HE SCORES.R ANDREI
>> Eddie: THE STRETCH PASS HAS
>> Kenny: PALAT DROPS THE PUCK
OFF FOR COLTON: SHOT.
SCORE!
IT'S McDAVID AND FIRE
IT BACK THE OTHER WAY.
WHAT A SHOT BY THE
OILERS.
>> Eddie: KUCHEROV MADE THAT
LOOK EASY.
BARRIE WITH THE PASS UP.